[Music]
do you see
elements of social realism in the modern
films that we have now like
mona i think it's called mona the one
that you analyzed mona moana
moana and then frozen and then
wonder woman yeah well right now we we
don't i would say that
we're not we're not using social realism
for our propaganda anymore
the uh because it's a different it's a
weird different um it's a weird
different world than than for example
early century early
one of the things that has happened is
let's say
the revolutionary elements of our
society they they've actually understood
symbolism they've been the ones who for
the past let's say 50 years
have understood symbolism the most and
so
they've actually been using
let's say mythological structures to
affect to you to affect their propaganda
it's very different
much like the nazi symbol being what was
it swastika was what yeah
was it i mean the swastika is one of the
most ancient images
one of the most ancient symbols that
exists it's it's uh it's an image that
is universal you can find it in all
cultures
uh you can find it in you can go to a
church medieval church and see swastikas
you can go to a hindu temple and see
swastikas
it is it's probably one of the oldest
images we have
and so they were able to to to take it
to
to to change it a little bit they made
it uh
instead of making it straight they
slanted it i think that it's in
the nazis are a really good example in a
way in the sense that the nazis
they wanted to co-op mythological
thinking more than others
they had a weird they also they had a
weird uh
religious feel to them right they they
had a kind of strange esoteric
and uh you know a desire to renew
to revive uh northern gods
they also had weird contacts with uh
with uh
indian the the the the uh the
aristocracy in india
with the uh um what are the names of
the cast and i can't remember anything
in the cast um so do you think that's
one of the reasons
why why these totalitarian regimes when
they come in particularly on the left so
particularly communist regimes that they
want to obliterate
traditional art and obliterate religion
and ban it oh for sure
because they understand it well they
because they they understand how
potent it is and also because especially
the communists the communist
uh groups they really wanted to because
they believe that the human person
is malleable right that we're a blank
slate type
and so what they they wanted to destroy
the
all the cultural tenets which were there
in order to bring about their utopia
you know the the chinese the russians
did it too russians liquidated they
destroyed the russians destroyed over 30
000 churches just during the early times
of stalin
and you know we all know that the maoist
cultural revolution was insane
you know they just went around
destroying not only destroying but
execute executing anybody that had to do
with the priesthood yeah
and the same thing i mean or buddhists
really early communists or russia
russians would go around you know and
just just
to shoot priests in the head you know it
was it was a cra it was an insane time
so it
was like liquidating the the uh
the imagery in order to bring about
their their utopia
but today we today it's weird
it's different our our version of that
let's say our version of propaganda
is a little different from that it's
more it's more insipid and it's more
it tends to understand like i said it
tends to be more subversive
rather than directly offensive in
in the sense that it's better to
instead of it's better to show
like the show in versions and to to to
to have stories with
the notion that the inverted is becomes
the
norm in a way and that seems to be the
way to that that a lot of
propaganda is happening now um and so
it's it's a bit different and so
sometimes
it's tricky because sometimes the
stories actually end up looking very
much
like ancient traditional stories it's
often just that they're upside down or
that there's a
like shrek is a great example shrek is
like the most
the easiest example to see where it
looks like a fairy tale but it's
actually an upside down it's a totally
upside down fairy tale
[Music]